it's still hard to believe we've been
thrust into this life-and-death moment
and easy to think it's only older people
who were really at risk for the most
part that is true but there are
exceptions Matt green shields from
Okotoks Alberta is one of them he's 19
years old
and he's just come through the fight of
his life he is one of the youngest
people in Canada to survive Coe bid 19
and he wants other young people to pay
attention Matt hi there I'm so glad
you're feeling well enough to talk to us
yeah a healthy 19 year old ear you
started out that way at least give us a
bit of a timeline you started feeling
sick in mid-march how quickly did it
deteriorate yeah so I started feeling
very mildly sick on the 12th and then I
came home to focus at the time I was
living on campus at University of
Calgary and then over the course of
being at home I felt like all my
symptoms had gone away
about eight days later and then on March
24th so 12 days later they all came back
at one and then I was admitted into the
hospital on 25th told I had kovat on the
26 and then told I had mono on the 27
and it was the combination the doctors
say that made you so sick and and you
ended up in intensive care
describe how you felt at that point well
physically I was not doing so well I was
in pretty rough shape because I was so
sick but mentally knowing that I was
going into the intensive there was
really hard to hear I remember the
doctors coming in and they they're
telling me we're gonna put you in the
intensive care for a potential
tracheotomy and I remember just not
saying anything I was just in total
shock because you know you hear stories
about iesous and what happens and you
never expect your own yourself to be in
there so it was terrifying and I guess
at that point you were also isolated
from your family right they had to stay
away from you what was that like for you
and enter your mom especially yeah I was
with my mom at the time in the hospital
when they told me that the kovin swab
came back positive and I was actually
asleep and so my mom had to wake me up
and break the news that she had to leave
in five minutes and so it kind of it was
that was definitely the hardest point
mentally for me just knowing that I
couldn't see anyone that I knew and
probably the scariest out of my whole
life and
yeah you know just like and the nurses
do I like I give my heart up the nurse
who had to give that news you know it's
just as hard for her to see that happen
as it is for us to take it and yeah it
was it was really tough
so for people who were your age give us
a real clear sense of how you were
feeling what this did to you how you
felt that night when you were in ICU
when I was in ICU I had never felt those
scared and so physically ill in my whole
life and I had never expected at all
like my tonsils and everything was
swollen to the point where I couldn't
communicate I couldn't breathe properly
and I couldn't swallow and so those
three things alone are enough to scare
like they were it was terrifying for me
and being so yeah um you know I never
expected to be in that sort of a spot
where I would need to be in intensive
care and so I guess it's a good way to
know that this really could happen to
anyone
do you have any idea where you caught
Kovac 19th that's a question that I
would like to know as well I don't have
any ideas but being at university and
living on campus it's such a diverse and
international place that I must have
just touched the wrong doorknob or
something just a free free thing that
I'd never expected you know you decided
to go public with your story I know what
what is it you want young people to know
about this virus yeah at first I didn't
want to go public just given how graphic
my own face was but then I was aware of
some people who were having small house
parties and gathering still like around
people that I know and and you know it's
just it's tough for me to see that
knowing what I went through and I don't
want anyone else to have to go through
that so I decided to come out publicly
with what happened to me to hopefully
raise awareness more of my peers and say
you know I don't know how I got it and
it could really happen to anyone did you
think at one point you might not make it
Matt yeah when I was being wheeled down
the ICU I was definitely starting to
finally question myself it's up at that
point I was thinking you know I'm just
gonna get over it it's just a sickness
like I'm young I'm healthy
but being wheeled down to the ICU and
being in those remote Hall
where there's nobody I was with my
thoughts and I was thinking you know
this is kind of like this is scary now
and then while I was in ICU and all of
my symptoms just exploded and peeked and
how much care I was being given I was
finally thinking like you know I don't
know how this is gonna turn out I don't
know how this is gonna end up so that
was definitely a very scary moment for
me to think that Matt you're looking
great now you're talking to us what's
your prognosis how are you doing I'm
doing much better now I've had a lot of
time to recover at home now
I've just been basically sleeping away
the days and trying to get better as
much as I can but yeah definitely better
than it was